you know but that i i i mean i'm sure
the price point is not going to be
consumer level but like imagine one day
where it's just like oh we just have a
a we have a security robot
that's going to happen without a doubt
in our lifetime my thing is like this
it's just like
these yeah i mean these robots
to some degree will have to be
self-automated and if not intelligent at
least artificial intelligence type thing
right
like one day this robot let's say you
bought this robot for your family right
and it lived with you the day's gonna
come where it's gonna become obsolete
so there's gonna be junkyards full of
these
old robots that serve no purpose anymore
and like are they going to be able to
think are they gonna be aware of their
situation
there's got to be a power down scenario
but is that [ __ ] cool
i mean you have rosie the [ __ ] maid
for 10 years and you're like well all
right well there's a new model we're
going to shut her down and just [ __ ]
ship her out wow that is
like that's what i worry about because i
worry about that with ted i'm like yeah
and that's not even that that's not
doesn't have any intelligence and but
i've bonded with it because i put the
[ __ ] googly eyes on it and i named it
and like one day ted's gonna go and i'm
sure i'll just toss him out but this
sort of thing living in your house being
part of your family and then you're just
like oh there's a new model let's get it
right you watch this what he was just
did he just knocked it out of his hand
and pushed him
no he shoved him back and the robot went
like flying back
and then came forward again this one
oh and you're you're fearing the day the
robot's not gonna take that [ __ ] they'd
roll it's like yo what was that about
yeah
that'd be great i i hope they play jazz
when they all get obsolete oh it's gonna
be weird man
think about that like there's going to
be a whole second market for robots
and like if a robot god forbid we come
to the era where robots actually have
some sort of self-intelligence and
feelings and [ __ ] but there's still
these [ __ ] they're considered objects
that is going to be a nightmare for
these robots i feel really bad about it
yeah and i bet you they'll oh my god
yeah we'll see how it plays out but they
might make the robots live in certain
areas look at that i don't even like
that he did that to the robot yeah like
suddenly you're like
from behind like okay it's just weird
because it looks like us but like
you're saying that at one point when
they achieve certain amount of whatever
but then they're looked at as just
robots
they're gonna have an issue with that
if you cover that in skin like good skin
did you see ex machina yeah one that was
crazy give me that robot yeah
but also but also don't yeah but all
right yeah i also don't want to be
locked in a room to start yeah i love
that i saw that movie two times in the
theater